there's an article in the guardian that
I want to point out and begin with and
all we really need is the headline the
guardian
panic and rash decision making ex-bud
light staff on one of the biggest
boycotts in U.S history
the article goes on to elaborate says
when Anheuser-Busch inbev the
multinational Beer Company promoted
Alyssa heinershine to vice president
marketing for Bud Light in July 2022 she
became the first female VP in the beer's
40-year history
it's just old white men she says one
former employee of the company
leadership that's why we were excited to
at least have Alyssa in that role in a
March 2023 interview with the lifestyle
podcast make yourself at home
heinershites spoke of her uh of her
remit and we've played that clip before
Alyssa Hunter said that's the clip of
the uh
woke female Bud Light executive talking
about how they want to change the
branding of uh Bud Light so it's not
just associated with white men and Frat
Boys anymore or make it more diverse
this was before the uh the the the
Mulvaney
promotion happen instead of ensuring a
prosperous future for Bud Light
heinershine's tenure was marked by a
sharp decline in sales and one of the
biggest boycotts of a brand in U.S
history after a minor social media
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney was
attacked by right-wing anti-trans groups
over the past month the guardian has
spoken with insiders at Bud Light and
the agency the company contracted about
what exactly happened and why the brand
refused to back Mulvaney during the
backlash former employees who wish to
remain anonymous spoke of leadership
incompetence and said that Executives
were operating from a place of fear and
were now vetting public comments under
the Brand's Instagram post to remove any
hint of negativity
Anheuser-Busch did not respond to
multiple requests for comments for this
story uh it goes on from there you know
the whole to Blanc so we get the inside
story from these various ex-bud light
employees who are very upset that the
company from their perspective uh caved
to pressure from us right-wing bigots
and it was just chaos and it was a
disaster behind the scenes and Bud Light
bungled everything every step of the way
they say which of course they did I mean
that part of it is true
um
but as I said the most important aspect
here can be seen just in the headline
one of the biggest boycotts in U.S
history
which first of all there's a there's a
real there's a lot of lessons here that
can be learned
a lot of lessons that Bud Light learned
the hard way
um you know don't promote transgenderism
is one of them
another one is you know as we hear they
were they were so excited we got a the
first female VP
this is this is very exciting this
diversity we're embracing diversity
and pretty much admitting that they they
hired her purely for that purely to sort
of check off the demographic box
and her whole job is to promote the
brand is to market the brand
and then almost as soon as she the first
female in this position almost as soon
as she gets into that position the
company tanks is destroyed
she she is she is there to oversee and
to engineer
um
the worst drop in sales in the history
of the company
so that's what you get for your
diversity initiatives
but it's also interesting just to see
the media finally acknowledging you know
calling it one of the biggest boycotts
in U.S history the media is finally
acknowledging that and you may remember
that in the beginning it was it was
different
uh that's not how it was they made fun
of the boycott the left the media did
they made fun of it as pathetic
toothless
there was a lot of skepticism for a long
time the boycott was actually uh you
know the skepticism that it would
accomplish anything
um skepticism from from people on the
left and the right
saying that this isn't going to go
anywhere
but now even the Hostile left-wing press
admits that the boycott was historic
truly historic
I mean there are very few examples of a
major brand suffering these kinds of
losses due to an organized boycott
and I actually can't think of any other
example period
I mean we always talked about the boy
the Bud Light boycott being
so significant because it was one of the
few examples of a conservative boycott
being successful was actually one of the
few examples of any boycott against a
major brand being actually successful
the left generally has boycotted much
more often and and they have the
reputation of being more effective at it
and they are you know up until the boy
the Bud Light thing they they typically
will have the more effective boycotts
not saying much
right the bar is pretty low to be more
effective
but boycotting whether you're on the
left or the right doesn't matter
boycotting a major iconic
American brand it's not even really
American anymore it's not owned by an
American company but uh traditionally
you know historically American brand
boycotting something like that is that
that is a tall order and to actually
make an impact
is very very difficult it rarely happens
to go as far as we were able to go with
the Bud Light boycott and just destroy
the company completely
um
is an entirely different matter
so I guess my point here is partly
partly it's I told you so
um and you know I love to say I told you
so and by you I don't mean you the
audience I mean them you know the left
the media
even the Skeptics on the right who said
the Bud Light boycott was a distraction
Etc
you know and listen people are allowed
to be wrong about things I've been wrong
about things in the past it may shock
you to learn so you're allowed to be
wrong
um
but the people on the right the
conservatives who were uh
kind of making fun of the Bud Light
boycott early on is this is going to do
anything this is stupid this is a
distraction you're not accomplishing
anything those people
okay and there are some prominent ones
trying to discourage it
say this is not we should even be doing
this
those people on the right who said that
now I know a few of them have come along
afterwards and say you know what I got
this one wrong so you guys you guys are
right this is the ballet boycott was
great
but the ones who haven't acknowledged
that then I I think you should keep that
in mind because that's a that is a major
uh blow to their credibility
that this is we want to talk about
impacts on the culture
one of the most impactful things that
the conservative movement has done in
modern history
and if you're a conservative and you
weren't
on our team and helping with that then
that's unfortunate
if you were trying to dissuade us from
doing it that's any that's even more
unfortunate and if you still haven't
admitted that hey I got that wrong you
guys were right next time I've learned
my lesson next time I'll be on board you
know what I've learned that uh that
actually you know the culture really
does matter
obviously
and being able to uh to to to exercise
power over a major American brand
you know that that that's that's a big
thing that matters I've learned that so
so if someone acknowledges that and
that's one thing but I think some of
them haven't
um
well what I said at the time and is is
that this was and it is
it's like it's an incredibly significant
moment
in in history it would actually it will
be in the history books this is again a
major iconic National brand brought to
its knees destroyed
not just by boycott
but by a boycott from the side of the
culture war that supposedly has no power
and no purchase and no sway
aside that crucially
believed it itself believed that it had
no power certainly didn't have this kind
of power
and so what makes it so incredibly
significant it's really it's two things
one
as I said all along
Bud Light this is the this is the you
know the head on the spike at the
outskirts of town it's a warning to
other brands
this is what could happen to you
okay and if you're if you are already in
a vowed left-wing brand
you know and this and this is what you
do and people expect it
and your and your your customers are
mostly uh left Wingers already yeah you
could get away with it probably you know
if you're Ben and Jerry's or whatever
you can get away with
but if you're if you're a mainstream
brand and especially if you're a brand
that relies on you know average
Americans conservatives
you need our business
then uh you better be very careful you
better tread very lightly
you know you might think you might you
you've you've
what you've learned in the past
is that yeah you convert your signal a
little bit you can throw a bone to the
left and uh try to win some some social
credit points
man it's not gonna hurt you on this side
because your customers because we're not
you know what we'll be forgiving of that
well those days are over we're not gonna
be forgiving them
so that was the first thing that made it
significant and and we immediately saw
the cascading kind of domino effect
of course this happened right before
pride month
and then we get into pride month
and then Target happens and Target gets
so it's kind of a not full Bud Light but
like a mini Bud Light treatment
and a lot of other brands did become it
was not you know I think many people
were expecting uh pride month in 2023 to
be just a total historic explosion of
rainbows everywhere and it wasn't quite
to the extent that many people were
expecting and the left noticed that too
now a lot of Articles written about how
uh Brands had a much more muted response
this time around a pride month why
because they're afraid because they saw
what happened to Bud Light
so that's the first thing that made it
incredibly significant the other thing
is because it you know it's the message
that's sent to Corporate America it's
also the message that it sends to to us
to the right
that we actually have this kind of power
we know we have the numbers we have
numbers we know that there's millions of
us
and um
that that means something and we can use
that to our advantage but but we have to
use it
we have to organize and actually use it
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there